In this lesson, we will examine a fast
Fourier transform and apply it in order
to obtain an efficient algorithm for
convolving two sequences of numbers.
If you have seen the Fourier transform
before in the context of mathematics,
physics or engineering,
this lesson may have a different
flavor from what you are used to.
We won't be using it to solve
differential equations or
to characterize the behavior
of an electrical circuit.
Instead, we'll be focused on
the much more mundane task
of multiplying polynomials and
doing it quickly.
This algorithmic aspect
of the Fourier transform
is actually almost as old as
the Fourier transform itself,
appearing in an early 19th century
paper by Gauss on interpolation.
The transform itself, by the way, gets
its paper from Jean Baptiste Fourier's
1807 paper on the propagation
of heat through solids.
Gauss' trick seems to have largely
been forgotten, until Cooley and
Tookey published a paper on
the fast Fourier transform in 1965.
Tookey was apparently somewhat
reluctant to publish the paper,
because he thought it was a simple
observation and the how to questions of
algorithms were still considered
second class at the time.
Well much has changed since then.
Their paper's now one of the most
cited scientific literature and
the idea is considered one of
the most elegant in algorithm design.